from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the Dave Ramsey
show where dead is dumb
cash is king in the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host we're glad you are with
us today for the last 30 years and I
from the time I turned on this
microphone until now we have had one
goal and that is to help you have a
better life you do that with knowledge
knowledge is power
you do that when you transform your life
your actions your habits your behaviors
as a part of that power that power gives
you the ability to transform your life
and God working with you blessing you
does that it's absolutely amazing and so
one of the things that keeps people from
winning in an area of their life like
money is bad products financial things
that we do that fall under the heading
of stupid that are set up to benefit the
company selling them and rip you off we
talk about them all the time we tell you
not to buy whole life life insurance we
tell you not to lease a car we tell you
not to use credit cards for God's sakes
stay off the payday lender lot and you
don't go in there and pay 800 percent
interest don't buy a stupid timeshare we
tell you these kinds of things all the
time
there are a few of these spaces where we
tell you the product is not only bad but
the vast majority of the people in the
industry are bad these are bad people
selling bad products in bad ways and
that makes it like a triple lose you got
to stay away from this but large
majority the payday lenders fall in that
category large majority of credit card
collectors fall in that category and the
large majority of timeshares fall in
that case
Gouri bad people selling a bad product
in a scummy scuzzy illegal lying
fraudulent manner on a regular basis as
standard practice of business we run
into it all the time we run into the
horror stories we get to hear from you
how you got screwed now granted you
walked in there you got the free
vacation in quotes which turns out to be
a high-pressure sales event that's two
and a half hours long and has promised
to be 30 minutes and there is no
vacation you spend all your time down
trying to get this person off of you
that is lying cheating stealing
conniving anything they can do to get
you to leave by one of their stupid but
Tom shares before you go and their every
word out of their mouth is a lie they're
scum it's unbelievable
I can't of all the industries now I've
had a few car dealers tell people Dave
Ramsey leased a car which is obviously a
lie I've had a few people say Dave
Ramsey as a credit card which is
obviously a lie but I hear every week
that sometimes chair salesman is telling
somebody the Dave Ramsey has a timeshare
I've never had a timeshare
I have done almost every stupid horrible
thing you can do with money but
timeshare is not on the list let me just
tell you there is not a condition the
only people selling timeshares are the
super high-end ones that you might want
to think about doing but even then I'm
not gonna recommend them for instance
Disney the Disney timeshares are a whole
different class of timeshare but most of
these things are just bottom feeder you
would not let any of these employees you
would not let the owners of these
companies in your home and yet you buy a
week of vacation from them and it is
awful if you have had eight words to
devote this hour to starting the process
of uncovering all of the misbehavior in
the timeshare industry it is
unbelievable when you get down in it how
filthy it is how filthy these people are
it's
evil if you have been lied to scammed
misled
have been pressured been beat up
whatever by the time sure call me I want
to talk to you this hour
I want to hear real stories from real
people I got plenty of them but if you
want to call right now the phone numbers
triple eight eight two five five two two
five three of the biggest misbehaviors
three of the biggest scum buggers in the
market our Diamond Resorts International
they're the king of bad Westgate and
Berkeley group which goes under vacation
village resorts now just go and Google
it takes ten minutes just Google Diamond
Resorts International or Westgate or
Berkeley group and you will see what I'm
talking about Google Wyndham you'll see
what I'm talking about you just ask
TripAdvisor
you you look at Yelp you look at the
Better Business Bureau
you just find straight not one or two
complaints pages and pages and pages and
pages and pages of misbehavior by these
people absolutely unbelievable they
don't transfer that date they don't let
you use the other property like they
said they don't give you the tickets
they said they try to throw you out
after they promise you a free vacation
like they said you know it's
unbelievable and they get sued all the
time
Westgate loses a suit for high-pressure
tactics and Tennessee here's an article
timeshare buyers Nathan and Patricia
Overton alleged that they were promised
many things when buying a timeshare unit
in Gatlinburg that later proved to be
untrue when you promise something in
business that proved to be untrue by the
way that's called fraud for example they
allege they were promised a specific
room during the Christmas season but
were later told it wasn't possible rooms
were only assigned a few days before the
visit
Westgate lost an appeal of the case
drawing critical opinion from the
appellate judge who wore him out engaged
in in the judge said Westgate engaged in
intentional and fraudulent conduct and
will
he violated both the Tennessee timeshare
act and the Tennessee consumer
protection act he wrote in his opinion
and this kid this article goes on and on
and on and on and on Westgate says this
is an isolated incident if it was an
isolated incident there wouldn't be
pages and pages and pages and pages of
people saying the same things about
Westgate about Diamond Resorts
International about Berkley group all
the time over and over and over and over
and they're unbelievable
here's some of the are here some of the
postings this is about Diamond Resorts
International Lisa says they are
terrible the last five years it's become
horrible increased HOA prices through
the roof I've been trying for six months
to get a reservation
I have annual points it's become
sickening they're out of control
owners owners must pay or we get
foreclosed on our credit yet our resort
time is never available this is fraud
I'm looking to get out of this thing I
think I need an attorney or a
class-action lawsuit cliff says to put
it bluntly diamond resort international
sales people are scum of the earth and
will tell you anything to get you to buy
then every time you visit a resort they
want you to suffer through another
arm-twisting confusing sales
presentation and you'll learn everything
they told you the last time was BS and
they proceeded to feed you new lies I'd
advise staying well clear of them hang
around here and find out about buying
good properties at resale rather than
retail this goes on and on and on I can
read these four days but I'm going to
talk to you two about experiences you've
had with the timeshare process the
filthy dirty apartment that you're
supposed to be getting the rent the
how bad a shape it's in the way that
people lie they lie did I mention they
lie this is the Dave Ramsey show we're
talking timeshare exits this hour we're
talking timeshare problems this hour
we're talking about the timeshare
industry and what a ripoff it is this
hour and want to hear from some of the
stories I've heard them but just talk to
some of you the phone numbers triple
eight eight two five five two two five
let's go to Shirley in Wisconsin I
surely welcome to the Dave Ramsey chef
hi Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's up
about seven years ago my husband and I
went down to Florida we love to go down
there and see the water and the
wintertime and get out of the woods
constant cold we went to a timeshare
because we run go to Disney and the
tickets are so expensive we thought we'd
save money go listen to the timeshare
we're gonna say no just got free stuff
and leave
so our two hours turned into five hours
you're in their sales room for five
hours
yes sir why did you not read for people
we're to Minnesota or I just live in
Minnesota you may say Minnesota nice oh
you're nice okay that's why okay yeah
I'm nice okay but anyway so we thought
we were pretty good we said no we got
out of there with our three tickets we
were so proud because we spent night
because all we could think about was gee
you know it's right outside of Disney
and everybody's gonna want to go there
and they showed us the unit that would
be like purchasing that would be our
place to stay it looks beautiful it was
all updated we had kids that are older
or empty nesters getting ready to be
empty nesters at that time we thought oh
they're gonna have to get married we can
use it for their honeymoon well as it
turns out we went up the next morning
and practically begged them if we could
still have a second chance at that same
time share because of that low $300 a
year maintenance fee so now we've got
$4,000 still left on it it was seven
years ago
good while we would be Financial Peace
University we started it the end of
January so we know how stupid we are
we are going through we will be debt
free including paying this off in 2023
will pay off one hundred and thirty five
thousand dollars and just have the house
left and that will be paid two years
after that Wow well good for you on that
one so they kept you in there five hours
and it worked because you went back the
next day yep yep and they're better so
denies normal so the $300 on maintenance
fee how'd that work out that has not
changed but we have a feeling that once
the unit is once our loan is paid off
that it will start going up yeah they
get you either with the loan of the
maintenance fee they keep getting the
same amount right that's what that's
what we keep hearing on them because
there's just scummy so that who owns
this particular timeshare what company
is that it's through Silver Lake Resort
through RCIA
okay all right and where you promised
that you could change it for a different
one if you wanted to go to a different
location yep yep yeah we're trying to do
that yes they showed us the map we've
gone back there three or four times to
them while we could we go to Florida
every year we can't find any place to
use their timeshare for that
so we've gifted it to some people we did
have a daughter get married we sent it
away it was great so you have been able
to get some other locations yep but it's
very worn there's been you know the
places that we do get our rundown
they're not exactly what they showed us
we have actually stayed at the resort
too but we don't get to places like they
showed us we're back by Animal Kingdom
where they had braces that go to a pool
o'clock in the morning so it's just a
bad deal the maintenance is that the
thing has gone down it's deteriorated
and have you complained about that yep
we were just there in February and said
well we just want to give it to back we
know we got 4,000 we won't pay the 4000
just take it back we just want to be
done with it because we don't want any
date on our credit or you know I know
we're not going to use credit but yeah
but they wouldn't do that of course they
said they only take them back at certain
times and this is no
yeah not when you're here yeah that
makes sense
yeah so with everything you've spent on
it with everything you've spent on it
over the years you could have gone to
nice places couldn't you oh sure yep
absolutely yeah so it doesn't end up
being a money-saving event and end up
being a money pit and you stay in places
that are pits yep exactly we can never
see where we want to stay like we like
to stay on the beaches you know the snow
they never have anything I've had a
ongoing search for eight months which
they promised I would always be able to
find something if I would just use that
I've tried that for two years and they
have not they paid you a dollar an hour
for the time you spent searching you
would have made your money back yep for
sure
Wow hey thanks for calling I'm sorry you
got ripped off you're not the only one
Jeff is in Idaho hi Jeff what's up hey I
just wanted to show you my story with
town in 2018 we went down to San Diego
our friend owned a timeshare down there
and he said people can just pay the cash
price which was a couple hundred dollars
to be able to stay three or four ninth
account remember exact amount of nights
but we checked in and of course they put
this self pressure on us too said he
come and take the tour and after the
tour you'll get a free night stay with
any of our resort's going forward so I
went back into the car and told my wife
about it and she was kind of perturbed
about it I said okay we'll give it a try
out they said it would be a minimum of
two hours I think it was about three
three and a half good lord
and the biggest thing yeah the biggest
thing we ran into though is what we're
singing no to this lady we have more
cute and she started telling us how that
of her parents we were because we
weren't providing vacations for our kids
no little eNOS yes I'm serious like my
wife has been kissed and I I was like
we're done we don't need any more in
this so focused probably 30 40 minutes
to get out of there I telling them no
we're done we're gonna move on I think
we're gonna get the free vacation but
we're so mad that was the beginning of
our trip our three or four days and it
made our trip terrible it was like kind
of annoying and then like you said you
the resort was like a very low-end motel
like that's what we felt like it was a
new fancy paid a couple hundred dollars
a night for it no boy that's a couple
hundred for the entire thing you know I
suggesting that I think it just drives
you remember the codeine IME there and I
think world marks is that son right who
world world
words mark young smart would be oh my
god be yeah alright yeah yeah well the
terrible experts my wife is just felt
and she was just so mad and just trying
to sell out of the parents we were and
and like you said they start getting
dirty with yeah
yeah how old were you like I said that's
a couple years ago 36 okay
alright because I I just man I think if
that ever happen to you again there's no
way you stay in there three hours right
correct can't think of anything we buy
anywhere that takes three hours to buy
it you know I don't spend three hours
buying a car you know it's just it's
funny how they just it that is the
manipulation of this is amazing hey
thanks for sharing that they told you
you were bad parents if you don't buy
now that's a technique that works pissed
the customer off see I'm telling you
these people are scum scum scum
Regina's in Kentucky hi Regina tell us
about it hi this was years ago but my
husband signed us up for a one of those
tours and Myrtle Beach you know and we
had free like two three nights of hotel
stay and then they offered like tickets
to to some of the attractions and free
meal as a restaurant and all that so we
go and we'll check in and seven of
course you got to use a credit card to
check in they've been they were gonna
pay it you know if you went to the I'm
sure to her so we go and at the time we
had three kids
and I left him with my friend she had
kids well she had to go like three to go
get her to go get her kids and I believe
if I'm remembering right the tour was
like at like news
come come my 2:30 we're still sitting in
that big room that is they drugged
ascended through the sales pitch and I
had tried it like a billion times they
just say no no we're not doing this and
she kept saying well soldier has crying
you know come out and find this freeze
that she can go and I was like I gotta
go so I went I got the kids and came
back with the kids and he was glad my
husband was still sitting in that room
and they won't let us go I mean they
just would not let us go that's exactly
how they work it Wow I would pinch the
kids and get them crying oh the scummy
timeshare industry we're talking about
it today this is the Dave Ramsey show
we're talking the scummy timeshare
industry and the horrible products that
they push and pressure and control you
into the number of times that they are
sued there is of course like there is in
any scummy industry a full spectrum of
bad actors from extremely bad actors all
the way up to not so bad actors probably
the best people in the business as you
might not be surprised as Disney and
they have legitimate products still not
a fan of the product but at least you
can sell it and they don't lie and
aren't sued for fraud and all this other
stuff like people like Diamond Resorts
International is or Westgate is or the
people at vacation village resorts the
berkeley group does the number of
complaints when you google these company
names on the internet is mind-blowing
I've never seen thing like an industry
that is hated as bad across the board by
their customers so we're taking your
timeshare nightmare calls your
experience in buying or trying to use a
timeshare and over the years I've done
this periodically I've never done a full
hour on it but I know a bunch of you are
getting ready to think about vacations
as you come out of your quarantine and I
don't want you to fall into one of these
things the last thing you want to do is
sign up for the
timeshare vacation and get stuck in a
room for five hours norm is in Michigan
norm to me your timeshare story yeah so
days thank you for taking my call truly
truly an honor to speak to you sir
Triana
you too sir yes I'm known from Michigan
not fear a nice Minnesota people i'm
michigan me so yeah we went to Las Vegas
about 15 years ago in my wife and I just
to get away for a time and we said I
will take this free tour well exactly
the free tour turned into four hours and
the last two hours we were pressured in
the office and I told the guy no no no
up to five times and I got up and walked
away twice only to become only to come
back and my ended up is almost an
argument and I was just right between
him and I because I wanted to leave my
wife understand so it's not very good
and and I would just say that you know
they're trying to earn a job trying to
do their job but but on the other side
you have to realize that you are setting
yourself up for a bad future in your
homee life and so people think about
that I know on the flip side of that
babe my brother and sister-in-law they
have a timeshare and we go with them and
we have enjoyed all the digits within
our state you feel but we pay them for
their use of their points yeah we take a
vacation hope do you remember the
company that theirs is worth it's a good
one there I think with a Marriott yeah
yeah I'm Marriott timeshares is there
right up there with Disney on the better
that they keep their properties up and
it's a much better much better situation
I've actually stayed in some Marriott
resorts just as a customer but not as a
timeshare user and it's the same
situation I swim the same units
and we do a lot of business with
Marriott so very cool do you remember
the company where you almost got in a
fight there's a bunch of them in Vegas
yeah yeah but we were there for vacation
but they once again truly an honor to
speak with you sir and and I followed
you not you offensive as I've stated I
paid for my own college I went to
college in my face with all my stones
and when I when I got done with college
I was 24 and I made a list
yes like what you said I made a list and
while I did this before I even knew
about you and I paid off smallest to
largest my car loan might buy my books
like tuition my blah blah blah and truly
an honor days you too sir
thank you thank you for sharing your
story norm appreciate you calling and
congratulations very good stuff all
right Terry is on the line in South
Carolina Tara tell us your time sure
nightmare hey babe me and my family went
to Myrtle Beach South Carolina one year
just like two years ago and that I Hotel
it was people in our lobby and saying
what the free tickets to the car show of
course one of three TVs with a lot of
other folks they was giving away I think
instead okay well you have to you know
go to the pool or whatever and the next
morning we meant we had free transfers
and everything it was like five hours
Neels children and we was ready to go we
had to go but they kept on pressing
about you know you can go to vacation by
the timeshare you go for free and
everything it was like like 20,000 or
30,000 dollars so what did the ticket
what the tickets that they gave you what
were the tickets they gave you worth
what did you get for trading five hours
of your life it was like $200 Wow it was
like $200 for five hours yeah here's a
sign in it and well we can't go home and
look over it is
it's just until at one time so we had
tried it and so we got back to the hotel
I started researching and it was like
full of an idea and it was 48 hours
before I could counsel so the rest of my
vacation it was miserable because I had
to go through the library in a library
card write out the calculation because
we was there for they'll be there for a
week but we only had 48 hours to counsel
so I spent the rest of my days and days
trying to count them this timeshare but
in this way it's like I read it before I
went home or I would have been sucked in
the timeshare Wow oh you got out of it
you cancelled it within the 48 hours
effectively and they didn't come after
you after that right I got to the hotel
I went and researched it and it was more
than a good idea yeah the best part of
all the bad reports that I'm talking
about that are all over the internet on
all these companies yeah you remember
the company name Wyndham yeah okay
they're one of the big ones yeah okay
yeah and they said we had I was
concerned about the maintenance when I
was there and they was like oh you could
just buy groceries with this car and
then you get points of you know I'll
stick a fee but then after I researched
it you have to my least five thousand
dollars worth of groceries so much
outfit even though fee so low like yeah
absolutely well I'm glad you got out of
it five hours five hours Diamond Resorts
had a class action filed on them to
consumers filed a proposed class action
lawsuit against Diamond Resorts
International Club in its land its
collection arm and Experian information
solutions over alleged in accuracies on
the credit report stemming from
terminated timeshare accounts according
the lawsuit out of California Central
District the plaintiffs obtained a
so-called membership with the Diamond
Resorts International to which they were
told they would acquire
Tom share points to be redeemed in
exchange for the right to use
accommodations at certain resorts
familiar familiar Lurie I can't even say
charged that Diamond Resorts
International no stranger to
class-action litigation used deceptive
sales practices and made numerous oral
misrepresentations and false statements
during their sales presentations aimed
to induce consumers into contracting
with the company the suit points out
that the plaintiffs went so far as to
file a proposed class action against
Diamond Resorts International over this
alleged conduct following the lawsuit
Diamond Resorts International agreed to
release the plaintiffs from their
contracts pursuant to a settlement which
waived and cancelled any and all
remaining balances so they had to sue
them to get out of it after they were
lied to over and over and over again and
that's one of the biggest players in the
market Diamond Resorts and really this
this this regular you just hear it over
and over and over we were trapped they
wouldn't let us go unbelievable if
you've got a timeshare story you can
call me crippled eight eight two five
five two two five this is the Dave
Ramsey show our Scripture of the day
romans 14:9 so then let us pursue what
makes for peace and for mutual up
building Arnold Palmer said always make
a total effort even when the odds are
against you
Jose says first I'll stay away from this
company they are sharks and will lie and
say anything to get you to buy their
timeshare we recently went to a westgate
Resorts tour to get a discount on Disney
tickets as usual we went and they to the
tour and listen to their pitch the sales
guy I dealt with promised just a
two-bedroom condo anywhere we wanted for
two hundred and forty seven dollars or
five hundred dollars depending on how
busy was they promised us it would not
exceed five hundred dollars and it was
100% for sure
247 or five hundred two months in this
has been a complete lie our timeshare
was about ten thousand plus the annual
fee and all the resort's we have looked
into are $1200 plus for a two-bedroom
and we cannot choose our dates they give
you the dates of their choice they lie
westgate Resorts there you go
Robbie is with us Robbie's in New Jersey
hey Robbie how are you I'm great Dave
thank you so much for taking my call
sure they're trying to get with you for
two years
I'm glad you did tell me your timeshare
nightmare so it was with Wyndham and I
was stupid more than what I bought a
Wyndham in San Antonio Texas in 2010
fast forward to 2017 I've used it down
it in in Maryland and the guide told me
that his mother had cancer you know and
and I'm married to a boxing coach
Olympic boxing coach though he did all
this flattery thing and we ended up
walking away from $19,000 all the way up
to $70,000 seventy seven thousand
dollars and he told us that we had to go
from all access to a deed we would never
be turned down so move forward to 2018
we got turned down for my birthday to go
to National Harbor Maryland we went to
the Poconos it was a wrap and I called
down and they moved us across the
landing on stairs that we had never we
told me couldn't do stairs because we're
older
and then they refused to give us the key
so we couldn't leave we were trapped
there on my birthday all day long
finally I got a chance to get out and
then they didn't bother us for a while
because apparently they change president
transformer to end of December of 2018
we were in Virginia young and they told
we had to go so we went the young man
ended up threatening us and told us that
we had to go back to all accent I told
him you know utilizing was you told me
that all that I would be able to do this
I'd be able to do that I would never be
turn down and he said well if you don't
drive this for additional thirty
thousand dollars will come after you
will come up in your family and I said
oh really
and something inside of me snapped and I
walked out I went and stopped payment I
wrote them a letter I went to the credit
reporting agencies and said this is
fraud they have lied to me and so they
let me out of the contract in November
of 2019 and I tried timeshare exiting I
was not impressed with a guy and at the
time it was our last debt and I when we
first thought women you own joint with a
deal you did you walked away from
seventy two thousand dollars by what I
walked away had gotten down to fifty
four thousand so you still owed them the
money yeah your finance what was the
interest rate you finance to that it was
at sixteen point nine nine percent good
gosh but then you finally talk to my
completely other deal by threatening to
sue them oh my goodness a $72,000
timeshare Wow
Robbie thanks for the call all right
let's go to chasity chastity in Alabama
chastity told me your timeshare story hi
babe my husband and I were staying with
someone from Windham down in Florida and
we got down there and they wanted us to
go to one of those presentations to get
free Disney tickets but kept us for six
hours we ended up buying what they call
a discovery package
we got three trips for $3,000 to
discover their program the people wanted
to sign up for a lifetime and every time
we went on the trip we had to go to one
of those presentations which was you
know at least two hours Wow
at what point did you say I don't ever
want to go to a timeshare presentation
again really bad then you signed up to
discover more of them right discovery
packages because once you discover it
why would you want to sign it for the
long haul yeah well that's true it's
like a bad sample it's like hey try a
sample of our cookie it's bad whoo I
don't want your cookies okay yeah you
have to go they paid you you paid them
$3,000 to get more presentations right
Wow now what was the condition what was
the condition of the properties like
well that you actually got to stay in
versus the ones they showed you in the
presentation the one that my friend gave
us the one and that closest to do mean
that one was like very very nice the
rest of them were okay not as nice as
that one but you cannot even get into
the one Odie's like he's one of the top
tier people and he could only get one
day there Wow I don't even want to think
about what it takes to be one of their
top tier people that just made my skin
crawl
oh my gosh hey thanks for sharing the
story we appreciate it
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so what's the
moral of the story the more the story is
there's 18 million of you listening and
I'm trying to tell you as you come out
of quarantine don't go for a 6-hour
pressure cooker thing presentation on a
timeshare in order to get a free night
your life is worth more than that don't
sell your time that cheap you've heard
the saying you don't get something for
nothing you don't get something for
nothing something for nothing
you don't if it sounds too good to be
true it is oh you just have to go to a
little sales president presentation or a
little tour and you get a couple of free
nights meanwhile you end up staying in a
fleabag situation dealing with scum of
the earth sales people who are not even
real sales people who call you a bad
parent you hear that story that was wild
you know threaten you the number of
elderly people in these complaints that
we find on the Internet are unbelievable
and this industry is just full of scum
and I got to tell you man I mean the
Marriott Group and the Disney Group - I
can I can sell you those products are
reasonable I would not buy them because
I don't believe in time shares period I
think they're a bad investment I think
it's a bad use of your money but it's
really bad when you deal with people
like this West Gate this Berkeley group
that has these vacation village resorts
all over the place and certainly the
king of scum which is Dimond
international I mean these guys of a
guess is where you're gonna find a lot
of these guys Gatlinburg and Myrtle
Beach is where you're gonna find a lot
of these guys and so you just need to be
you know don't just don't go into those
situations and what lesson ask yourself
what's wrong with me that would allow me
to sit there for six hours because I got
to tell you I'd be there for 30 minutes
and I'm gone but that's me and I'm you
know I'm not easily intimidated
obviously so I don't understand
that they prey on people being nice they
prey on people with manners they prey
they take advantage of you being trying
to be kind and so since that doesn't
work being kind is not an option with
these people they apparently only
understand one thing and that's a punch
in the nose so we'll give them one
like for the last hour telling 18
million people you suck there we go
there's a punch in the nose as you suck
your industry sucks you're scummy people
it's a scummy business it's a ripoff
people stay away from them
please stay away from them hope I wasn't
unclear I would never want to be unclear
that puts this our the Dave Ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]